so unless you've been living under a
rock for the past 20 years you're
probably well acquainted with Jenny From
the Block whether it's from being a pop
icon starring in rom-coms like made in
Manhattan headlining the Super Bowl or
being the other half of benifer 2.0 JLo
is killing it at life and given that she
looks like she's being stuck in a time
capsule everyone and their grandma wants
to know about her Wellness routine so
let's talk about it The Good The Bad and
The downright misinformed hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we'll be taking a look at Triple Threat
Superstar and newlywed Jennifer Lopez
but first we're going to play a little
game called Abby's daily hunger crush
and combo this time from the comfort of
my car so I'm about to go pick up my son
from school and there's usually like
crazy traffic so I always have to keep
some little snackies in the car in case
I got hungry on the way so today
we got some roasted almonds for some
healthy fats we got an Apple for some
Fiber and I've got one of my bill bar
Puffs for my protein you guys know I
love these bars because they taste like
chocolate because they're made with real
chocolate plus they have 15 grams or
more of protein per bar this one's got
17 grams and it tastes like a
marshmallow coated in chocolatey
goodness
um
so good these keep me in a good mood
even when I'm battling traffic and I've
got really cranky kits in the back so if
you want to try a bill bar for yourself
you can check out my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it is not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen we're going to start with a bit
of an older interview from her but it
does seem like it's the most consistent
representation that I've seen pretty
much everybody else quote so obviously
we do not know if this is how JLo eats
today or every day but regardless as
usual I'm just using this as teachable
material I usually start off with a
shake in the morning okay so this makes
total sense for a busy working woman on
the Move smoothies can be a great and
efficient source of nutrition and hers
sounds like on the calories but at least
has some balance with some Fiber from
the berries some protein and fats from
the Greek yogurt and some extra protein
in the protein powder but if you ever
down a smoothie and then feel like
you're like still ready to eat it's not
just your mind playing tricks on you
research suggests that smoothies are
often less satiating compared to if you
were to eat each individual ingredient
even if the total calories are exactly
the same and this is because liquids
kind of bypass a lot of the important
digestive steps and they move through
your system a lot faster than whole food
so even though smoothies can be a
convenient way to get in lots of
nutrition super fast they might not hold
you over as long as the food that you
chew it's also worth noting that a lot
of influencers will insist that you chew
your smoothie to stimulate the digestive
enzymes in your saliva and while this
theoretically makes sense for better
digestion it may not necessarily help
with the status faction Factor so to
bump up the satiety I suggest pairing it
with some toasted Nut Butter a couple
eggs or a handful of some nuts on the
side I also want to add that JLo's been
on the record for saying that she
completely avoids caffeine because it
wrecks your skin and will instead drink
lots of water throughout the day to stay
hydrated we love a hydrated Queen and
research does suggest that water plays a
small role in maintaining skin hydration
however I wouldn't say that coffee is
the antithesis to water when it comes to
skin Health caffeine is at best a mild
diuretic with no significant differences
in urine output from folks who drink
water versus coffee coffee is water it's
actually almost 99 water so it's not
going to dry out your skin as long as
you're staying hydrated it also has some
benefits for skin since it's a good
source of antioxidants which combat free
radical damage that can negatively
impact the skin in fact we have research
showing that coffee drinkers have a
lower risk of certain skin cancers
however there is a bit of a Nuance here
as you could potentially argue that
caffeine could negatively impact your
skin if it makes you feel really anxious
because you're consuming an excessive
amount as we know that increased
cortisol levels can trigger acne
breakouts also what you put in your
coffee may also play a role here
especially if you find things like Dairy
and sugar to be potential culprits
behind your breakouts but overall any
negative impact that coffee specifically
may have on the skin really depends on
your unique sensitivity to caffeine and
what else you put inside but for most
folks moderate coffee consumption is not
going to wreck your skin then after that
you know probably like right before
lunch I start getting really hungry I
have like a little bit of fruit or you
know a bar or something like that so I'm
not surprised that she starts to feel
hungry shortly after breakfast given
that her smoothie only had like 250
calories Max and was completely liquid
so we definitely would want see that
bumped up and again I think that fruit
or bars can be a great portable quickie
snack but if we enjoy them together
rather than like an either or we'd have
a much better hunger crushing combo and
a more well-balanced dose of
macronutrients and then I'll have a
lunch and it'd usually be something
yummy and again I don't like giving up
yummy food like that's a big deal for me
but it'll be something
like you know chicken and salad or
vegetables or quinoa or something like
that and again I learned that doing the
plant-based program that I did I am all
for not giving up the foods that you
love and I find that this is all too
often the first thing to go in a lot of
rigid celeb diets and I also think that
chicken salad vegetables and quinoa are
yummy well not quinoa quinoa sucks but I
was totally expecting the statement
about not giving up yummy foods to be
followed by something I don't know a
little less diety I mean if chicken and
salad truly is what lights up JLo's life
then amazing I am so glad that she won't
give it up
[Music]
but it makes me wonder what not so yummy
meals she's making herself eat anyway as
for the yummy lunch itself we've got a
good balance of fiber in the veggies
quinoa for carbs and fiber and chicken
for some protein ideally I'd love to see
some healthy fats in there whether it's
from an oil-based dressing nuts avocado
or even swapping the chicken for salmon
on some days so even though it's very
like celebesque to have salad for lunch
it doesn't sound like JLo is one to just
eat a pile of lettuce for lunch and then
call it a day and considering how
Physically Active she is as a performer
she definitely needs to have enough fuel
in the tank to bring her A-game and then
um at night sometimes I just eat
whatever I want to be honest it's like
it's dinner time I'm gonna have a good
meal with my kids
I think a lot of it has to do with
portion control I don't deprive myself
of things I you don't need to if you're
pregnant yeah I I just try to moderate
it a little bit so if I want to have you
know a little bit of rice and beans and
because that's what I grew up with and
some and some steak or whatever I could
do that like most people with families
dinner is usually kind of unpredictable
and varied because it's often shared
with others so again I like that JLo
doesn't limit herself to a handful of
diet friendly foods but rather eats what
sounds good to her that day but also
prioritizing eating a meal as a family
and this is a great example of how food
is so much more than just fuel it brings
us together in community with our loved
ones and it's a vehicle to nourish our
spirit just as much as our physical body
cultural Foods likewise play an
important role in connecting with our
cultural identity so I think that it's
great that JLo honors her Puerto Rican
roots by eating cultural foods like rice
and beans and getting to share that
experience with her kids
as for the comment on portion control I
get that this was her way of saying that
she tries to eat in moderation and this
is what allows her to be flexible but I
also want to highlight that portion
control can still be limiting if it
doesn't align with your body's innate
satiety signals so sure you can serve
yourself a small portion of food so that
you don't feel deprived of it but what
happens if you finish your small portion
and your hunger signals are still on
full blast this is not something that
you can necessarily portion control your
way out of your body still needs to eat
it still needs more food even if it's
deemed unhealthy food so it's okay to
give yourself permission to rely on an
internal measure of fullness rather than
an external source of how much food you
allegedly should be eating when we
idealize one thing it's unhealthy for
everybody else and so I think the idea
of being curvaceous being a little bit
bigger than normal or smaller than
normal all of it's okay so long as it's
healthy so long as it's healthy and
there shouldn't be one ideal of what
beautiful is I can imagine JLo has gone
through her own journey of body
acceptance after being ridiculed in the
media for having a booty when it was in
Vogue to have a thigh gap and while in
the last decade we've seen her
particular body type celebrated thanks
to people like the Kardashians and their
sought after bbls it now seems like
we're kind of going back to the wave
thin air as I discussed in my video
right here my guess or at least my hope
is that we won't be seeing JLo dieting
down to a size zero just to fit the
current Trend unlike some other major
celebs in the game so I appreciate JLo
at least calling out that Health isn't a
one size fits all however I do also want
to touch on the line about it's okay so
long as it's healthy I know what she's
saying and at face value this seems like
the kind of PC body positive thing to
say your body Size Doesn't Matter your
health does and this is a huge
conversation but I'll just say that this
is a common belief that is rooted in
ableism and access but the respect and
kindness that we show to another human
should never be contingent on their
perceived Health we don't owe anyone a
confirmation of our health status and
unless you are a person's doctor
interpreting their Labs we'll never know
if their body is healthy if that's even
how we want to Define health what about
mental and emotional health like how do
we gauge that bottom line I appreciate
JLo's statement because I think it came
from a good place but I also just want
to invite everyone who has said the same
thing from a place of love and care to
think about disproportionate access to
health and what bearing that may have on
a person's worth just some food for
thought but back to JLo while it would
seem from this older interview that she
advocates for body acceptance and
enjoying food her controversial no sugar
no carbs 10-day detox challenge tells a
slightly different tale I'm a sugar and
carb like that's most of my diet yeah
and he's like well let's just cut it out
I was like completely like cold turkey
for someone who claims that it's a big
deal to not cut out yummy food I'm
surprised that she agreed to cut out
something that she loves and that
apparently makes up most of her diet I
am fiercely against these stupid
challenges unless you can see yourself
sticking to these types of dietary
changes for the long run there's really
no point in participating in them for
some kind of quick fix because whatever
progress you might achieve during those
10 days will immediately get undone on
day 11 when you face plant into a plate
of cinnamon buns like and you're
thinking I'm thinking about it all the
time I'm like when I can have sugar
again I'm gonna have cookies and then
I'm gonna have bread and then I'm gonna
have bread with butter and I'm just like
yep that sounds about right the issue
with these types of challenges is that
any extended period of restriction is
almost always followed immediately by
some kind of binge or overeating episode
and once you are in the clear and
finally have permission to eat like you
normally would you are actually more
likely to overcompensate on calories and
effectively undo any caloric defs that
you may have had during those 10 days
this is precisely why we do not take
nutrition advice from unqualified
nutrition coaches or personal trainers
like who the [ __ ] wants to spend 10
precious days in an alternate universe
where all you can think about is bread
and cookies this woman is way too busy
for her headspace to be consumed by this
first and second day what you realize is
that you're addicted to Sugar yeah like
it's like crack it's like crack you
crave it it's like a drug and and to be
honest it is a reason we have so much
inflammation and so many toxins in our
body and so my trainer challenged us
because he knows I love to eat cookies
yeah and he's like all right he's like
you've got to like scale back on the TV
like just reset your body where we start
getting you on healthier carved folks
you can start incorporating more healthy
high fiber carbs any day anytime you do
not need a 10 Day Detox or reset to
start doing that also your body is not a
Wi-Fi modem that you can like disconnect
for 10 seconds and then reset your body
is a well-oiled machine that still needs
adequate calories to function optimally
so starving the body of calories and its
preferred energy source AKA carbs
especially for someone as active as JLo
will do nothing besides slow you down
and make you miserable which I'd argue
is actually the opposite of a reset we
also can't be painting all cars with the
same inflammatory brush high fiber carbs
like fruits veggies legumes and whole
grains are loaded with antioxidants
which are actually anti-inflammatory for
the body I would even argue that the
hunger misery and stress that you would
endure on a detox like this would play
an even greater role in inflammation in
the body by increasing the stress
hormone cortisol which we know is
associated with increased markers of
inflammation so please
just don't you will lose you know a
bunch of pounds on air you will lose
inches because it's just the nature once
you get rid of that sugar and those
carbs it just starts coming off reminder
that any weight loss during this 10 day
challenge is likely predominantly water
weight with possibly small amounts of
fat and muscle the latter of which we do
not want to lose but it takes about two
to four days to clear your glycogen
stores and the water bound to them after
going on a very very low carb diet which
usually leads to a modest drop in weight
of around 1 to 10 pounds but again given
that this is a temporary diet any water
weight lost will come right back at the
end of the 10 days when you go back to
eating carbs and any body fat that may
have been lost from restriction will
also likely come right back after you've
binged onset carbs so yeah there really
isn't a great Roi for this challenge so
let's sum this bad boy up as some
someone who advocates for self-care not
depriving yourself of the foods that you
love and embracing your body shape just
the way it is as long as it's healthy I
am a little disappointed Jayla would
participate in such an unhealthy cleanse
at the same time I can really empathize
with celebrities like JLo along with
literally everyone else on social media
right now I mean no one is immune to the
pressures of diet culture especially in
Hollywood when the advice that you're
getting is from people that you trust
like your trainer but even if changing
her body was absolutely necessary for a
particular role I would have much rather
she'd do it in a safe and sustainable
way rather than a quick temporary fix
that may actually have resulted in more
negative implications for her body and
mind such as Boomerang weight gain and
unnecessary stress and if she still
needed to do this 10 Day Detox at least
do not publicize it for everybody else
to call copy this will do absolutely
nothing good for the young
impressionable girls and women who
idolize her so is the 10-day detox to
thank for JLo's physique and Youthful
glow
how about new if anything a lot of it is
likely to do with the cumulative effects
of more gentle and sustainable aspects
of her lifestyle like hydration
sunscreen use quality sleep extensive
physical activity a nutrient-rich diet
and of course in large part due to
genetics as well so this is a reminder
that next time you hear that your
favorite celeb is trialing a detox or a
fad diet that makes them feel like
they're in an alternate universe take it
as a sign to just like keep on scrolling
stay here in this universe where we
focus on long-term habits that work and
speaking of habits you can check out my
video on my top weight loss tips right
here and on that note that's all that I
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what or who
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]